all right this little king david we're
the r with the lords i'm here with
everborn creator and host of uh on the
real sir and also the creator of the
everboy soccer and everyone universe
everything to deal with everyone the man
is a complete genius i'm happy to share
this uh night with him in this preview
we're going to see uh shane chief i'm
well versed in the character and my
thoughts on going to see the character
is uh
steeped in marvel history
everyone doesn't know the character
listen uh i it'd just be better be
better than iron fist that's all i'm
looking for okay so all right so the
expectations of it is what
through the roof because a lot of
reviewers that i trust like right now
this thing has a 99 percent audience
score and i think it's at a nine yard
rotten tomatoes but like you say
uh what you eat don't make me
exact right so i gotta judge it for
myself but like i said you can go by
people you trust and the people that i
trust
say
top notch and then i've i've heard i've
heard it called the best uh comic book
movie since
oh
all right so i mean i've been avoiding
any type of interpretations any type of
reviews anything about the film and what
we're going to give you is the pre this
is the pre we'll give you the pulse
after we're about to go to a closed
screen of it uh
all due to my man ever born i'm so happy
that i could share the space with him
again like i said and we'll come right
back to you after this all right so now
we're at the post
of r and r with the lords
again i'm with everborn
creator and host of on the real
and
host and owner of everything everyone
saga
and everyone universe seriously so we
just seen shane turner hh
top 10
mcu
see now it's really about him right now
because
he knows nothing of the character i want
to know how he feels about the character
what he thought about the movie and
everything i just i just want to know
everything so
for me like i said this is not really
one of the characters i was familiar
with uh coming up with the marvel
universe or whatever so i was just
judging it as a movie right i'm not
judging it as an adaptation because i
don't know the character but as a film
that's that structure like if you are
into it i'm gonna give you some uh what
what it looks like with some inspiration
here right you remember probably tiger
hidden dragons
yeah you saw over the rumble in the
bronx in the bus
yes you saw a little bit of uh godzilla
king of monsters in that third act yes
sir you saw a little bit of the
never-ending story with a tray you ride
in the you know what yes exactly
that's it right this is spoiler free
this is the spoiler-free one right so so
what i'm saying is whatever you thought
you saw in the trailer
they they left all the cards on the
table you have no idea what you're going
to get so for me
high praise and like i said this is in
top 10
mcu like top tier
all right okay so
question in origin film because this is
the origin film character uh shanghi
that we're getting to know in marvel
it's an origin film my top origin film
is black panther correct okay
that's my ceiling
the floor would probably be somewhere
like captain america uh the first movie
yes
so
where would you rank this as an origin
film
as an origin film i think i think it's
up there and i i
it's hard for me to call black panther
uh an origin film only because you had a
civil war right kind of set him on the
journey right so so for
i don't know that iron man
is right
yeah exactly
when we're talking about origins yeah
there we go i'm just this is yours
so for me
it's hard i got i have to think about it
but it's up there okay now we had uh
the winter soldier as the top
hand-to-hand combat movie that marvel's
ever created i think this has his basket
leaps and bounds i think this is the
best hand-to-hand combat that i've ever
seen from a marvel film and it shows
with the the choreographers they brought
in for the fight scenes my question to
you
is how do you rank this as fight scene
wise
now
we have to clarify here right we are
talking about hand-to-hand skills combat
we're not talking about best fight team
because i would love that's right
somewhere else good we're talking about
hand-to-hand
man-to-man
he is number one in the mcu okay but
that again that's that is hand to hand
right right listen this is this no no no
no no no no
for me
the best fight team you've ever seen in
the mcu was an infinity war with dr
strange versus thanos and iron man and
spider-man okay so okay so all right so
what i'm what i'm talking about is the
the movement between two individuals
from seniors right so as uh from jumping
from individual to individual i thought
this did it well
as far as what we've never saw from say
iron fist or any other
combat movements unfortunately
yeah well see i think barbara stepped
out of the box and
they went forward with this uh film let
me tell you something about the fight
scenes and fight choreography that a lot
of people don't really pay attention to
you know we're dealing with top-tier
fight choreography when you don't have a
million cuts when you have a long shot
that can show them you can think and the
only way to do that is with time and
practice and they do it over and over
again that is what they did in the
matrix that is what they do here that is
what they did in the winter so so then
you notice the long shot yes
and they use the long shot a lot in this
film what i did appreciate about the
film is the asian culture that they did
show us they showed us a ton of asian
culture they went heavy mysticism in
this where i felt that they were shying
away from it in certain parts now
there's there's two endings in this film
there's a mixing credit there's an end
scene credit which will both blow your
mind there's a lot of easter eggs in
this film that will blow your mind this
is the spoiler free cast we're not gonna
do that but i will definitely be on the
real next thursday to talk about more
stuff with shang chi
yes sir all praises do he got us here we
had a great showing private nice quiet
movie dinner nobody else in there just
us let's all due and praises to this man
hey private is the only way to go that's
how you do it like private jets watching
movies in the private screening i'm
telling you
you